Ok. I tape i do. It's tuesday
the 2nd of march 1993.
I'm in sydney
and john cedars in lismore we're doing
a two way for under the rainbow.
John can i get is start by
introducing who you are and
when you first came to nimbin
air and how you are you see.
So describe how you fit in well. My
name's john seed and presently i'm.
I guess a rainforest conservationist
and eco philosopher.
I arrived in nimbin august 1973.
I'd been living in england for five years
and was on my way back to australia
travelling for about nine months overland
through asia meditating in india
and nepal studying meditation
and i never heard of nimbin or the aquarius
festival tomorrow of back in august
and then.
A good friend of mine carol elliott who's
you know a pretty important figure.
I think in the nimbin story carol
elliott and norman stannard
when i got to sydney with my wife greater.
They said oh you've got to go up to nimbin
and we've got a place there you
can stay out on crofton zero.
So we drove straight up. We
didn't like sydney too much.
We drove straight up and well
it's been here ever since.
Can you tell us about those early
days in how you started out.
Well i remember carol
and norman saying well
when you get to nimbin just go to
the rainbow cafe and ask for jimbo.
And i thought i you know i just thought
of an australian cafe and i thought i.
That's an unusual name for a cafe
the rainbow and we got to nimbin
and there was the rainbow
exactly where it is now
and we got there just in time for dinner
which was a communal meal around. One.
Long table
and basically i realized later the
whole of the new settler community in
that region was sitting around
that table that night you know
that everyone had gone
back from the festival
and there was just a
handful of people maybe 20
or 30 people left after the festival and
they were all sitting around that table.
So it's grown a lot since then.
So you did you see yourself as part of
that back to the earth movement were you
there too. You know to get back to.
You know starting your own
plot building your own her.
Well i i quickly came
to see myself that way
that wasn't my original intention in going
up there originally i just moved to the
country and i had you know some interesting
communities i've been part of a.
Kind of abortive attempt at a community
in northern california a couple of years
previously that only lasted a few months
but i had you know had time to by go
and create my first garden which was in
a spiral and. You know but but quickly.
I came to you know be very
much part of that movement
and i was part of the original
group of shareholders in the dream
that of coordination co-operative
that then went on to become the community
attainable falls and both greater
and i bought shares in that before you
know there was any land or anything like
that we just bought
shares in that dream and.
But i myself was looking for a more spiritual
community i said i wanted to you know
i'd been meditating in
india and nepal as i say
and as soon as we arrived in australia
we made contact with an english.
Buddhist monk he was a you know wearing
thai buddhist robes called prior candy
parlow who was teaching
meditation at the chinese.
These buddhist society index and street in
sydney and we invited him up and he did.
The first meditation retreats
i think it was still in 73
or maybe 74 we organized maybe i
over the next couple of years five
or six meditation retreats for him which
i think you know had quite a profound
influence on the direction
of that community.
Most of the people who were up there at
that time were you know took part in one
or more of those retreats and so.
I was looking for a more you know cohesive
integrated like minded community of
people who are committed to
personal and spiritual growth
and co-ordination co-operative
and tangible were always a
little bit to kind of crazy
and wild for my own
tastes at that time and.
So in 1975.
Dhammananda which is a community
into rainier creek road
that had actually started before
the aquarius festival they bought
that land i think in 71 or 72 and.
The land stretch from training a creek
up to wallace road on the ridge
that separates rainier creek
from tangible creek and.
Dhammananda donated a section of their
land on top of that ridge for the dream
that i had had and that i shared
with them of a meditation centre
and so in 1975.
Several of us began to build
up there we built a shed in 75
and started to you know build the
foundations for a meditation centre
and then later in 75.
I went back to india.
Again for more meditation
and to spend some time with a teacher a
woman called vimal issaka who also came
back and forth teaching.
In australia and up in the nimbin area
a few times over the years after that.
And at that time. In dallas.
How she in the himalayas.
While i was there to spend some time
with the miller and norman stannard
and carol elliot who started birth and
beyond in nimbin the home birthing.
You know midwives i guess they.
They and i met in dalhousie to be with
their miller and we also met another.
Thai buddhist monk an englishman
whose name now is christopher titmus
and he's quite a famous.
Progressive meditation teacher
who lives in england now
and he's no longer a monk but.
He was in dalhousie carol and norman
were doing a meditation retreat with him
and a whole bunch of young
western as were there.
So i went looking for carol in norman
walking up the side of this beautiful
mountain and i came around
a turn of the mountain
and there was this little child shop.
You know like a little tea shop called a
tired man's delight overlooking the you
know plain of the ganges
many thousands of feet below
and there's a whole bunch of young western
as there are americans new zealanders
australians sitting around drinking coffee
and eating sweet cakes from
this meditation retreat.
And i sat down with them and
within five minutes we had agreed
that they you know a whole bunch of them
were coming over to help build this
meditation centre and
that we were going to then look
for a piece of land nearby to buy
and to grow our food and
build our houses and
that we'd be caretakers of
the meditation centre and
that was what actually happened.
So within about 10 minutes
of that meeting the next.
I guess at least the next five years of my
life were pretty well laid out on a map
and what we discussed there
was exactly what happened.
Christopher came to australia
a few months later.
Maybe about maybe nearly a year later to
lead the first meditation retreat at this
meditation centre that we had
built in the meantime and the.
Participants in there was
actually three retreats
and maybe about 50 participants in each
so out of those hundred fifty people we
found 20 who wanted to share that
dream of a spiritual community
and we each put in a thousand
bucks and bought body farm.
So that was in 75 76
and basically up until the two
rainier creek action in 79.
That was my life. There are
my son was born there.
His name is bodie he's 15 now and
he he was the first child born on
that farm so it was named after it
and we build our own houses and.
You know raised our kids and grew
organic fruit and veggies and stuff
and lived a very pure and
beautiful life there.
Tells about some of the the rules. Of
body farm some of the the ethics etc..
Well it was a very very highly ethical
society we lived by the buddhist precepts of
no killing stealing lying drugs or alcohol
and no sexual misconduct.
I meaning you know you know
sexual conduct that hurt anyone
and we didn't keep any animals
either domestic animals
or you know livestock.
We just want didn't want to have any fences
we just wanted to live with the animals
from the bush and we didn't want any
dogs or cats getting into the bush
and we had a forest management
policy which left 95 percent of the
hundred sixty acres that we bought
was left as bush and the only areas
that we cleared where areas that had
previously been cleared. You know so about.
You know maybe about a 10 per cent of the
land about 16 acres i'd say maximum we
maintained for our buildings
and our agric. I'll check.
We looked after each other
and shared most of our things in common
we shared all of our motor vehicles
that in those early days for instance and.
We had a communal meal every
day we cooked for each other
and you know i just
looked after each other.
There was no doors necessary on the buildings
no one you know it was totally safe
place to have kids
and we're also you know very interested in
social action if this was out our style
of buddhism was what you
might call engaged buddhism
and we were involved in the
social issues of those days.
Specially the home birth
movement which was illegal
and we you know participated in
those illegal home births we felt
that it was everybody's right
to take birth and death
and these things back back from
authorities and back into our own hands
and it's kind of a bit unreal now looking
back on it you know like everything's
changed so much since those days
but it was a very beautiful time we built
16 illegal to a lings on this place.
There was no.
Multiple occupancy wasn't allowed then
in fact it was partly the court cases.
The 16 demolition orders that
were put onto our buildings
that were part of the you
know part of the trigger.
You know or the part of the whole thing
that created multiple occupancy in new
south wales. Looking back on those times.
Now do you do you think in some ways
you are too hard on yourself. So.
Oh no not at all.
I mean if we were to try and do
that from a sense of sacrifice
or a you know i just a sense
of duty or anything like
that it would have been terribly difficult
but it was totally passionate desire you
know we were following our bliss our
ecstasy and i can't think that any of
us have ever been happy. Since then.
Do you know but things change and
times change. We were on a wave.
You know and when you're on a wave.
It's easier just catch the
wave and you stay on it
but if you have to swim in the same direction
it's a different matter. You know.
So we were on a wave and it was great.
There's no sense of failure in the fact
that a lot of those the level of sharing
and stuff that was happening
then isn't still happening now.
But if i'm well i mean.
It's easy to get into that you know like
idealizing the past or something like
that
but it's i don't think it's a sense of
failure it's a body farm is an incredibly
beautiful place now and in
fact i'm living there again.
I've been away for quite some years
but i've moved back there again
and i think it's fantastic.
And the fact that there's only one communal
meal or two a week now and the fact
that people don't share their cars anymore
because it was just such a hassle
maintaining you know a shared vehicles
and you know you know
other things that you
and other thing at the beginning was
that no one owned their buildings
that anyone who built a
building on the land.
It belonged to the land so
that you know if you left.
You just it was left there for someone
else do you know and so there's no buying
or selling of buildings. That's
kind of changed a little bit.
I mean you know not not totally
but you know things you know
things change people get older
and i think it's still great.
What about the strain on
relationships at a place like boat.
But if i'm in those as we go.
Well i don't think i can't remember
anything anything particular.
You know i mean i don't think
that there was such a strain
on relationships i think
that there's a huge strain on relationships
in the nuclear family situation where
the only people that you have that you
close to you know are you know like three
or four people
and then with them they're on top of you
all the time place like body farm all.
The kids had you know a dozen you know
people that they loved and that they held
and were close to and so if
your parents were off the air.
It just didn't matter so much.
You know and also there was you know
levels of sharing and communion
and intimacy that i think you know
that that's how we're meant to live.
Really you know that's how we.
That's that's how our tribes were
for hundreds of thousands of years
and i think it's a terrible strain
to try and live any other way.
Can you tell us about the development of
the green lobby of the throne for its
information center and
where you fit into that.
Well that goes back to august 79
when you know rainier creek blew up
and this was i made a modest start again.
And so you know to make it a statement.
Back in our lot of well back in 1979 in
august i went to the channon market which
is a monthly craft and produce market
down the chain and just near body farm
and.
Some of our neighbors from down in the
valley at rainier creek appealed for help.
They'd been struggling
for five years to try
and stop the forestry commission
from logging the end of
that valley rainforest down there
and they the forestry commission were
coming in the following day with bulldozers
and they wanted neighbours to help to do a
blockade and that seemed very. You know.
Far away for me.
From what i was interested in i
was interested in meditation
and organic gardening and stuff
but somehow the next day along with i think
just about everyone from body farm i
found myself down there with a few
hundred people and we did this blockade
and it was incredible and somehow
or rather a lot of people were very very
moved their lives were moved by that
but my life was totally transformed
and in fact within two years it had pulled
me off body farm entirely but it's.
Started more slowly than that and i was
sort of back and forth but you know
when i was in the rainforest i
heard it screaming you know
and i heard it screaming for help
and over the next couple
of years at training creek
and later on in the campaign
for the nightcap range
and the rainforest of new south wales
i became more and more my life
and the life of the rainforest
became enmeshed so in 1981
having learnt about the plight of the
rainforests in many other countries
and empowered by our success in really
being able to do something you know moving
from a situation in august 79 where most
people had never even heard of rainforests
let alone knew their
significance to eighty two.
When the rand government made their stark
decision to protect the rainforest of new
south wales. We felt incredibly empowered
that ordinary people who didn't
have any particular training
or background could really do
something and we'd also learnt
that the rainforest of the
world were threatened that.
They contained more than 50 per cent
of the world's species of plants
and animals
and at the current rates of destruction
they would be utterly annihilated within
our own lifetime and
that this would be unprecedented in the
history of the world that and also
that many scientists warned that
if we allowed this to happen.
The life support systems of
the earth would be destroyed
and complex life would vanish from the
earth within a few human generations so.
We also discovered in writing
to groups around the world
that there wasn't a
single group at that time
that had the world's
rainforests on its agenda.
So that's when we started the rainforest
information centre in this more
and began networking
and trying to create a network around the
world to work on forest problems in you
know indonesia and brazil
in malaysia in new guinea
and other countries where
the kind of conch.
Yes an os that we developed
didn't exist as yet.
And meanwhile we were still
very very active in.
Issues in australia rainforest
issues from the franklin where about
or 15 of us from the lismore area were invited
down by the wilderness society to help
set up their blockade of
the franklin river in 83
and then also up to the daintree where
most of the people at the daintree protest
also came from the you know the from the
nimbin it's rainy creek lismore area and.
Not only rainforest issues in 180 we did
blockades at middle head in the mid-north
coast of new south wales to stop
a sand mining operation there
and also we were very
involved in pine gap and.
A lot of the women were involved in the
women's actions in those days the warship
actions trying to stop the nuclear powered
and american warships from entering
australian waters and so on.
I guess there's traditionally been a lot
of resentment i guess because of because
of the fact
that there's been a lot of people at the
forefront of those movements from the an
end and by a north coast area.
Do you have any apologies for that
or oh no i mean i just think people
are so ungrateful. You know.
I mean you look at the
opinion polls and it's shows
that 90 per cent of everyone thinks that
we need environmental thing and so on
and so on
and no one really acknowledges where
the where the you know where the lead.
You know from that came from and
i know that it's unpopular and
that makes me you know i have all the more
admiration for the people that did it.
Here was this totally thankless
task where people are abused
and vilified for waking everybody up.
You know it's like people want to stay
asleep people would rather choke to death on
their own vomit in their sleep
then wake up i don't know.
So i don't feel apologetic
at all as you can hear.
Ok what about the role
of green extremists.
And what about the term romo worries
do you do this. Socio with that.
Oh well i mean i don't you know i'm not
sort of quite romantic like that myself.
You know i make no good but i can
i get you to start again and make
that a statement. Well i
mean i don't i don't.
I don't associate myself don't think
of myself as a as a rainbow warrior
or anything romantic like that
but i am a green extremist
and i guess i am a rainbow warrior i
mean if that meaning has you know if
that word has any meaning and i think
that i'm surrounded by green extremists
and rainbow warriors here.
The local forest protection society haha
so-called you know the loggers wives
and the rest. They started
a group called rage
and it's something like stands for something
like rage against green extremists
or something like that.
So their own first information center
printed these t-shirts with green extremist
across the front and huge letters
and it's our most popular item
you see everywhere around here
that we sell hundreds of. You know
people are proud to be green extremists.
Can you tell us a bit about
your spiritual journey
and you're developing your
relationship with the rainforest and.
And that that side of it.
Well you know this developed slowly
from those years but i don't know yet
but i can feel so much my spiritual journey
changed from a buddhist perspective to
what i would call deep
ecology over those years.
In the buddhist perspective
really mind and spirit
and the inner life of
human beings is primary
but it quickly became clear to me
in the rainforest that my body
and my mind how devolved within these
very forest over the last hundred fifty
million years ago when. The first flight.
Our implants in the world were
evolving in gone to ana land the giant
supercontinent included
south america and australia
and antarctica covered
in rainforest the place
that is now cape tribulation the first
flowering plants the angio sperms were
developing my answers to some kind of
little rodent scurrying around you know
trying to get out from under the dinosaurs
a hundred thirty million years ago now
since that time my body and my mind
have evolved to where i am now and.
To try and separate the spiritual
life from that incredible miracle of
that evolution it seems to me is a very
futile task and also a dangerous one.
Because as a result of the
way that we despise nature
and think of the earth as
just dirt and having no soul.
Having no intelligence and no life
and by denying our connection with
that i mean if we understand our
own evil lucian then we realize
that we are just like a leaf
on the tree of life and
that if we're alive then it's
only because the tree is alive
and if we're intelligent it's only part
of a tiny fragment of the intelligence of
the tree.
So here's the earth which holds
maybe 10 million species of plants
and animals in incredible symbiosis
and cooperation and partnership
and we are one of those how can we
call that you know how can we think of
that as being dead how can we think of
that as having no soul so very much.
My spiritual journey became one of surrendering
to the body of which i am just one
cell the body of gaia the
living earth and finding
that it's very easy to read receive
instruction and meaning for my life from
that that in the same way as you know my
heart beats and you know my lungs work
and my fingernails grow you know
and they all grow they cooperate
in order to create the integration
that is this body. So i feel. We humans.
If we will let go of our futile kind
of self-interest with the small
ass and recognize
that our own self-interest can't be other
than the interests of the earth of which
we are just a tiny fragment do you
know then you know once we understand
that then it's very easy for our lives
to fall back into harmony again with the
earth in the way that of course our
ancestors lives must have been in harmony
or they wouldn't have survived for a
minute you look around at every tree
and every plant every animal and it
lives in harmony with the earth.
It doesn't struggle against the earth
and it is receives its
instructions for the earth.
It knows how to feed itself how
to breeze how to reproduce itself
but we in our arrogance thinking ourselves
superior to nature have kind of shut
ourselves off from that but
the good news is that all
that we have to do is let go of
that arrogance and recognize
that we are merely part of the earth
merely miraculously part of the earth
and then we too can fall back
into harmony with the earth again
and it's only by doing this i believe
that our race that our species
and indeed complex life at all
will be supported on the earth.
We are the last generation of human
beings that will be in a position to make
that decision. It's clear
from david suzuki says
that we have less than 10 years before
the damage to the life support systems
reaches the point of no
return the damage to the air
and the water in the soil the poisoning of
the earth these these things will reach
a point of no return very very soon and
that unless we take responsibility for.
You know caring for the earth correctly
living correctly on the earth our children
won't get a chance
and no future generation of humans will
have a chance because it will be too late
but that can't come from
a sense of sacrifice
or a sense of duty as long as we
feel separate from nature and think
that you know that we have
to somehow. Protect this.
I think the environment you know something
over there is separate from us then
we're doomed to failure.
It's only when we realize
that we are the environment
that every breath we take nexus to the
earth every drop of water or food
that passes into our body connects
us to the earth we are connected.
It's just that we ignore that connection
and we define ourselves as
purely spiritual beings whatever
that might mean you know once we once we
realize that we are part of the earth
and the spiritual thing is
actually very down to earth.
Anyone who wants to prove this to themselves
only has to hold their breath for
three minutes.
You know anyone holding their breath for
three minutes will quickly realize what
i'm talking about we can call it the
atmosphere and think that it's over there
and that it's not really in our self-interest
to protect it. You know stop the sea.
If seas and so on.
You know but it's not the atmosphere
it's part of our own body
that we're talking about and
by projecting it out there.
We're destroying ourselves and we're
destroying the earth once we acknowledge
that it's part of us. Then there's no
sacrifice necessary in order to protect it.
You know someone's soaring our leg off we
don't sort of say look i'm too busy to
protect it. We know it's part of us
and you know we just do whatever we have
to do so anyway that's my spiritual
position i guess.
I guess the detractors of the the
aquarian ideals who would say
that people who moved to the nimbin area.
20 years ago were saying
the same things then
that we only had you know
less than ten years left.
But look we know we're still
here and it hasn't happened.
Doomsday stuff hasn't happened. Well. So.
I think it has happened but.
I mean you know look around you look
at what's happening to the world.
It's you know it's just a tragedy.
You know but you know the poisoning
of the air and the oceans
and the quality of life deteriorating
and so on but anyway i'm.
Personally not saying
that it is going to happen in 10 years
myself i'm quoting david suzuki who says
that i myself feel that the earth has
more resilience than that but the fact
that this is coming very very soon.
I don't think that there's any
doubt about that we're losing.
An average of more than 200 species
every day. This can't go on.
There's a finite you know there's
there's there's only so much
that the earth can take i think
everybody knows this. Anyway.
You know this high i don't
think many people would say
that anymore i think most people would
if they really honest with themselves
realized that this can't go on.
Can you tell it's a bit about
the way that you explored
that by spirituality i'm thinking of the
council of all beings which was something
that you instigated and you co-wrote
a book called thinking like amount.
Can you expand on some of themes
that though. Well you know.
This deep ecology philosophy which i've
kind of been expanding you know was very
satisfying but i realized that
it didn't change anything
that we could have these ideas
but it was still terribly difficult to
change our behavior and as i looked into
that.
I say ok
so the council of all beings was an
attempt to bring deep ecology to life to
actually change our behavior and.
One of the things
that i realized as i was studying
this problem is of how is it
that we human beings can be so
stupid as to saw off the very branch
that we ourselves are sitting on i mean we
why do we do we want to commit suicide.
What are we doing. How come it's so
difficult to change and i realize
that we modern humans are the first
civilization in the history of the world to
dispense with the rituals and
ceremonies that all other people's have
and still do practice quit.
Acknowledge and nurture that
interconnectedness between human beings
and the rest of the earth
community that it seems as though
that sense of interconnectedness which all
other species have you know i mean baboo
nz and flowers never forget
that they're part of the earth.
You know never occurs to them.
So we humans of the first ones to think
that we might be something special
something superior something different
and the way that we've you know
remained connected to the earth
and remained part of the great symphony
and not just got lost in our own ideas
and thoughts was with these
ceremonies in these rituals
and so the council of all beings
is a modern version of this.
It's a way in which through a couple
of days of ceremony and ritual
and
and communion with each other we can
reestablish not the idea of deep ecology
but the living experience of deep
ecology the living experience
that the earth is my body and once i feel
that the earth is my body it becomes much
much simpler to defend the earth because
it's i'm no longer defending
something outside myself
and so it's like it wasn't the right.
It wasn't me as a separate being defending
the rainforest the environment.
I became that part of the rainforest.
That was acting in its own self-defense
and of course self defense
is much much easier.
It doesn't require any great nobility
or any great you know special qualities
anybody can defend themselves.
Can you tell us a bit about what happens
you know during those three days in the
car if we will all beings what are people
actually do to get to come around to
that. Well i did it first
of all i'd have to say
that the council of all
beings can consist of all.